now when you look at this little guy I
as was mentioned right this looks like a
washer if you don't know what a washer
looks like that's what it looks like
okay okay it's like a flat sort of sheet
of metal and there's our it's round and
it there's a hole that's also round
touch them okay now because this is not
a cylinder because this is not a salary
if I were to ask you to calculate this
volume using two unit methods what would
you have done as a two-unit student what
would you have done for me okay so you
would have gone straight to hear right
you would do this with this big volume I
guess with this guy right and then you'd
say I'll seen this part in the middle I
can treat that as a second problem i'll
do this all over again and then on to us
a difference in volumes right I'll do
volume one takeaway volume two okay but
what I'm trying to do down in and look
at it say I don't have to think of them
as cylinders I don't have to think of
them as Silver's I can just add these
guys okay now because this is an
important shape we give it a name it's
called an annulus
and because excuse me because what
you've got here is a slice of this whole
volume we originally call this working
out in volume by slices okay that's
actually the name of this technique and
you've been doing this for a long time
four months down okay so it's just
putting a slightly different name on the
important thing is the slices you have
are not just plainly submit your call
these were always just to deal with the
cord axis right if we understand this we
can lift this pass we can do like things
right so because it's called an
ambulance and we're dealing slices they
are also called and your life that's the
adjective slices different name same
thing sore what gives them volume or my
slice well I've got I know how to work
with the volumes of cylinders and
essentially is some annular slice this
annulus is still what you said before
it's the difference of two cylinders
okay so let's work out what the volume
of this thing is do the easy part first
okay you've got this with you yes we've
got this with now i am going to dads
apart even though I I said I want to use
this H here I'm going to stop using that
now because one of the problems with
using H is that I don't know where this
distance is I can't specify where it is
unlike here and here you see these these
are both the height of the cylinder but
these are better yeah do you agree
because I can specify which height that
way is going ok which way that height is
going now I can't use the X because i'm
going to use that what I've got my
integral and that's already taken the
limits right so instead i'm going to
introduce a new meta which is a lower
case of delta the capital Delta is the
triangle of course which you see what's
up so that's a lowercase Delta I'll draw
a big one over here so you can see the
way of doing it it's kind of like an
incomplete eight if you like so mrs. i'm
going to call this Delta X I obviously
the the height of this annulus and then
I need to other dimensions what are the
debentures do I need what are the
dimensions of this object to any to work
out I told you yeah yeah
okay so this thing has two radii right
has it out of one and an inner one so if
you've got your your IVA color here
you've enjoyed this through let's extend
our access to the middle yard right like
soon okay literally through the middle
[ __ ] yeah yes and fought the center my
diagrams not quite on the center but you
get the idea I want to measure this
distance which I'm going to call the
inner radius and i also want to measure
this distance which are going to call
the outer radius you can name these
whatever you like in column y 1 y 2 or x
1 x 2 if you go around a different
access I like calling them bigger excuse
me smaller because the label itself
tells you what it is now remembering
that as we take different annular slices
these radii going to change right so you
remember I said over here hey ah it's a
function like it's not a constant what
am I ready i equal to in this case good
so the small one gets its height from
this lower line right that's where
that's more on X every single time for
whatever value of x you like and in the
same way you've got ear the x over here
because the high or rather do this
outside radius always gets its length
from the height on this function okay so
now I can say I go all the pieces i need
i'm going to say therefore the volume is
and again rather than going straight to
this right which actually disguises it
sort of veils over all of the sort of
the machinery happy on me I live there
for this slide but it's got a little
different because I'm not adding
cylinders anymore i'm adding annular
slices i think it is an your life but
I've never heard that said in fact that
sounded weak enough so i'm going to say
annular slices because that's not there
I need a live in right because this
Delta X right it needs to approach zero
to actually be equal to the volume
otherwise I just have it approximation
so they'll inner as
Delta X approaches 0 of this sum of
angular slices right I have a given
value C so again just going to call baby
from x equals a to x equals B it is
going to be pie because it's still a
roughly circular thing but the
difference here is well yeah here is
we're going to make it my difference and
annulus is the difference between two
cylinders so what am I going to put in
here okay very good I'm gonna do one
step before that because that step is
correct for this particular case I'm
just going to write a square take away
until our square because that's what
these functions are fraught and then
I've got Delta x over here that's the
height of my annulus not the height of a
cylinder it's the hideaway annulus now
here's the important thing I want to
point out before we just go ahead and
write the next line doing this right
this is what I meant by swapping the
engine right this is the engine that
makes the whole volume work Thank You
the calculation if I can change her
Mesilla got a bunch of cylinders to a
bunch of annular slices there's no
reason why I can't change it to anything
I like you could put anything in there
right so long as you can think of your
volume your chosen volume as an infinite
set of infant the sum of an infant set
of infinitely thin these things they
don't have to be so honest they don't
have to be annular slices they don't I'm
going to have to all be the same shape
they could be squares triangles whatever
you want right this is what i mean by
we've got a bit deeper we've pulled the
veil back but that's going to allow us
to extend and work out all kinds of
weird I comfortable right let's just
quickly evaluate this all of this stuff
now now that I've accounted for it i am
going to convert it into an integral
okay it goes from A to B I can put this
pie up the front because it's a closet
coefficient does it affect the
integration and they did here I actually
got to put it what is my cat will ask
for
what is my lower case R squared what
have I got for the style into the 2x and
having done with the limit right it's it
ok now I'm treating this thing this
thing has the little bit bakey to it I'm
done now let's think about this where am
I going to go to next ok yeah that's
what I want you to put again you're
probably running man Thomas right but
the first way we were thinking about
this was as a difference of volumes
right the difference all volumes ok
workout volume 1 and then subtract
volume 2 but what I've done is I tried
to purchase a different way I don't want
to do any subtractions at all if I can
avoid them I want to add things up
because then I can change the things
that my ad so instead of taking a
difference of volumes right oh I should
say a difference of cylinders I'm taking
the sum of these slices and what I've
done is I baked the difference into the
slice ok it's a very very subtle shift
ok but enormously powerful